the one thing that makes tattoos
different is that they're elective you
choose to put them on you because they
are something you want to express about
yourself in mid-2016 federal and local
law enforcement we're on the lookout for
gang members in a few US cities if you
comb through videos like these releases
to the public by the feds you'll notice
how interested cops are in tattoos
because gang members often get tattoos
it's nothing out of the norm for a gang
arrests officers make a record of the
tattoos just as they do for fingerprints
law enforcement has huge sets of tattoos
they've long had binders that people
flip through to look for gang tattoos
and other kinds of things but now like a
lot of different processes they want to
automated that's Dave Moss an
investigative researcher at the
Electronic Frontier Foundation by
automation he means capturing images of
tattoos and compiling them at a
computerized database to see if the
information can be used in
crime-fighting so there's a lot of
different kinds of biometrics that law
enforcement is interested in they're
interested in fingerprints they're
interested in faces maybe the ways you
walk they might be interested in your
irises or you know your DNA the one
thing that makes tattoos different is
that they're elective you choose to put
them on you because they are something
you want to express about yourself that
could include everything from your
everyday lower back tattoo to a basic
barbed wire around your arm but also
deeply personal political cultural and
religious symbols anybody out there have
it don't tread on me flag tattoo or
perhaps a Juggalo hatchet man yeah
looking at you you lovable weirdos oh
and that's why Moss says that the
automation of tattoo recognition may
seem effective when going after criminal
street gangs but also ushers in a new
world were innocent people without gang
affiliation may be unnecessarily under
the magnifying glass of law enforcement
you know those people who have the power
to charge you with a crime so for
example the six pointed star that's
something that you usually associate
with Judaism however that is also the
symbol of a gang in Chicago so if
they're entering the six pointed star
into a gang database saying that people
who have this are more likely to be
members of the Chicago gang than people
who you know are expect you know
expressing you know
right in Judaism and get a six-pointed
star may find themselves marked that way
and beyond that some gang members leave
gangs and move on with their lives so
later on they may be the targets of
harassment by the cops over the
meaningless ink on their skin but aren't
tattoos a public statement to the world
something that says who we are without
actually having to say it you're walking
down the street you put your tattoo on
your arm it's a publicly available thing
you lose your right to privacy you walk
around in public I mean I would I
wouldn't
to an extent yes you you're out in
public you are showing things off but a
lot of the tattoos we saw our tattoos
under people's shirts under bunch of
people's chests on people's private
areas mas is talking about images used
in research by the National Institute of
Standards and Technology or NIST a
government institution who partners with
the FBI on biometrics easily and
accurately ascertaining the identity of
individuals is what biometric systems
are all about and the FBI worked with
NIST to compile a large database of some
15,000 plus images of tattoos to start
testing how various algorithms can match
tattoos but if you look closely at the
research you can see how law enforcement
could easily identify certain groups of
people and they're definitely looking
for religious or what they say is like
ritual realistic tattoos right so this
is interesting cuz this is something
that they've now redacted or retro
actively removed from a lot of their
material with the series of studies that
they started off with they had a few
goals one of the goals was to match
people who have similar tattoos in
practice the idea would be okay so this
is what a certain gangs tattoo looks
like can we match all of the gang
members who have the similar tattoo and
then we have this good network of gang
members but that's not what they were
using in the actual research in the
research they were frequently using
images like the cross Jesus on the
crucifix hands praying with a rosary
those were images they use time and time
again and in practice with this research
once you put one cross up there you're
pulling up everybody else who has a
cross
and you know ultimately creating a list
of people who have tattoos of a certain
religion miss denied this to us in an
email saying their research was not
about discerning meaning from tattoos or
categorizing people based on tattoos and
all that they were trying to do was help
ensure the technology was evaluated
using sound science that improved
accuracy but regardless of the intent
the ability to match or find similarity
in tattoos is the point of the research
and even though NIST is saying they
aren't discerning meaning here the cops
could definitely discern meaning after
all the FBI has a well publicized
history of profiling people with their
religion in mind to really understand
the concerns automated tattoo
recognition would mean for people you
have to imagine the big data world
policing it's moving towards most of
that is hard to see for sure but whether
it's drones with cameras license plate
readers that can location track or
closed-circuit cameras that can
recognize your face law enforcement
wants to know as much as they can about
citizens and tattoos are a part of that
I do see that there is a public safety
interest on law enforcement to track
gang members but the question is at what
point are we actually talking about a
gang or we're just talking about a club
of people or people who have a First
Amendment a right to associate you know
if you can identify that there is a
criminal enterprise involved alright I
can see that but when you're capturing
tattoos of every single person walking
in the door or you're starting to apply
tattoo recognition to CCTV or if you're
scraping tattoos off of Facebook and
using that to identify people just in
general I mean that's worrisome that's
how are we worried about with facial
recognition that it's not just about
tracking criminals but tracking everyone
tattoos could function in the same way
[Music]